when i started to go through some of
these workshops and therapies and
coaches i opened up for the first time
about being sexually abused it felt like
i was gonna die
when i said this if anyone ever knew
that i'd been sexually abused no one
would ever love me
people would shame me for the rest of my
life i'd have no friends i'd make no
money and i'd be alone that was the
irrational fear that consumed my life i
didn't have the awareness
the model of someone like i've been
sexually abused and here's how to deal
with it i later thought i was the only
one
i was like i must be a bad person for
this to happen i need to hide this i
need to mask myself
to look good to accomplish to hide the
shame it worked in the sense of like i
accomplished but
man was i alone sad insecure
for many many years and i didn't learn
true vulnerability until
30 when i started to practice it and
it's extremely uncomfortable but i also
found out this
is probably the greatest superpower in
the world revealing who you are to
someone
in a vulnerable way makes you powerful